Haley is with us in the Charlotte North
Carolina hi Haley how are you hi Dave
I'm well how are you
that is an undeserved welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show how can I help okay so
I just started on the baby steps last
month I'm currently on baby step two and
I'm trying to adjust my tax allowances
so that I get more take-home pay per
month and then next year I don't have a
tax refund so my question is am I
allowed to claim dependents if I don't
have any absolutely okay you can claim
46 dependents and not have even a dog
okay the cool thing you're not allowed
to do without getting penalized is to
claim so many dependents that um that
you end up owing taxes right big amounts
of taxes because that defeats the
purpose of tax withholding and they will
penalize you for that but um my daughter
for instance Denise my oldest one when
she came out of school she went to work
for a non-profit for a while and her
first year I think we had we calculated
it out and she had to claim like six
dependents in order to break even in
order to have the proper amount withheld
because the IRS tables are inaccurate
they suck yes they do
and so um how old are you I'm thirty and
how much was your refund
last year it was $4,600 goodness
gracious and and has anything changed
from last year to this year in terms of
your life that you get married as your
taxes change or you make a lot more or a
lot less you know okay if everything is
about the same then it's a fairly simple
calculation we take $4,600 and divide it
by 12 which we will find to be about 380
bucks okay and we find that then we find
out the number of dependents you have to
claim to take about three hundred eighty
dollars a month more home and you'll be
right at forty six hundred magically and
I don't know what that number is you may
see a little bit of trial and error
and if you end up getting a small refund
of $100 or something that's okay but as
you have already figured out loaning the
government $4,600 for the year as a bad
plan because they don't pay interest
right yeah but so how many dependents
did you claim last year I only claim to
myself okay I'm going to start with
claiming one and two since I'm single
now I think you're probably going to
have to go to four or maybe five I have
your payroll department work with you
and figure out what just change your
take-home pay run some trial and error
don't I mean you have to do it
physically but just tell me I calculate
tell me what my take-home pay would be
if I claim for tell me what my take-home
pay would be if I claim five tell me
what it'd be if I claim six until you
get to about $380 increase okay that's
what I'm saying and then you know
they'll tell you know have them run it
until you get pretty close without going
over you know you don't want to take
home $400 because then you're going to
end up on a couple hundred bucks next
year right and assuming everything is
exactly the same next year which we
don't know for sure but that's going to
be pretty close and you know that way
you won't get in a mess and you won't
have a whole big refund so that's how
you do it though just have them run a
calculation for you two or three
different ways until you get to that
take-home pay is increased by forty six
hundred dollars a year which i think is
about $380 a month give or take
something like that so a good question
and good heads up on that way to watch
what you're doing in case you hadn't
figured out folks Santa Claus does not
live in Washington DC and he is not
sending you money because he likes you
if you get a tax refund think about if
you go to a store and get a refund you
know what that means means you gave them
money and they're giving you your money
back that's a refund and so if you get a
refund I mean you gave the IRS too much
money and that's what we were talking
about with Haley she had too much taken
out of her check $4,600 too much taken
out of her check
last year and so effectively she loaned
the government $5,000 almost for the
year and they didn't pay her a diamond
interest and then they give it back to
you in April and you guys are like
really I got a tax refund okay don't go
be celebrating stupidity because it's
dumb to loan the government money right
you agree yeah you do agree I used to do
that stuff too but you got to break
these habits of that you know normal
people do Hailey's doing a good job of
doing that
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]